The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
MEHRAN KARDAR: OK, let's start.
So in this class,
we focused mostly
on having some slab of material
and having some configuration
of some kind of a field inside.
And we said that,
basically, we are
going to be interested
close to, let's say,
phase transition and some
quantity that changes
at the phase transition.
We are interested in figuring
out the singularities
associated with that.
And we can coarse grain.
Once we have coarse grained, we
have the field m, potentially
a vector, that is characterized
throughout this material.
So it's a field
that's function of x.
And by integrating out over
a lot of degrees of freedom,
we can focus on the
probability of finding
different configurations
of this field.
And this probability
we constructed
on the basis of a number
of simple assumptions
such as locality, which
implied that we would write
this probability as a
product of contributions
of different parts, which in the
exponent becomes an integral.
And then we would put
within this all kinds
of things that are consistent
with the symmetries
of the problem.
So if, for example,
this is a field that
is invariant on
the rotations, we
would be having terms such as
m squared, m to the fourth,
and so forth.
But the interesting thing
was that, of course,
there is some interaction
with the neighborhoods.
Those neighborhood interactions
we can, in the continuum limit,
inclement by putting terms that
are proportional to radiant
of m and so forth.
So there is a lot
of things that you
could put consistent
with symmetry
and presumably be as
general as possible.
You could have
this and the terms
in this coefficients
of this expansion would
be these phenomenological
parameters characterizing
this probability,
function of all kinds
of microscopic
degrees of freedom,
as well as microscopic
constraints
such as temperature,
pressures, et cetera.
Now the question that we have
is if I start with a system,
let's say a configuration
where everybody's pointing up
or some other configuration
that is not the equilibrium
configuration, how
does the probability
evolve to become
something like this?
Now we are interested
therefore in m
that is a function
of position and time.
And since I want to use t for
time, this coefficient of m
squared that we were
previously calling t,
I will indicate by r, OK?
There are various types
of dynamics that you
can look at for this problem.
I will look at the class
that is dissipative.
And its inspiration
is the Brownian motion
that we discussed
last time where
we saw that when you put
a particle in a fluid
to a very good approximation
when the fluid is viscous,
it is the velocity that is
proportional to the force
and you can't ignore inertial
effects such as mass times
acceleration and you
write an equation
that is linear in position.
Velocity is the
linear derivative
of position, which
is the variable that
is of interest to you.
So here the variable that
is of interest to us,
is this magnetization that is
changing as a function of time.
And the equation
that we write down
is the derivative of this
field with respect to time.
And again, for the
Brownian motion,
the velocity was
proportional to the force.
The constant of proportionality
was some kind of a mobility
that you would
have in the fluid.
So continuing with
that inspiration,
let's put some kind
of a mobility here.
I should really put a
vector field here, but just
for convenience, let's
just focus on one component
and see what happens.
Now what is the force?
Presumably, each
location individually
feels some kind of a force.
And typically when we had the
Brownian particle, the force
we were getting
from the derivative
of the potential with
respect to the [? aviation ?]
of the position, the field
that we are interested.
So the analog of our
potential is the energy
that we have over here,
and in the same sense
that we want this effective
potential, if you like,
to govern the
equilibrium behavior--
and again, recall that for the
case of the Brownian particle,
eventually the probability was
related to the potential by e
to the minus beta v. This
is the analog of beta v, now
considered in the entire field.
So the analog of the force is
a derivative of this beta H,
so this would be our beta H
with respect to the variable
that I'm trying to change.
And since I don't have just
one variable, but a field,
the analog of the derivative
becomes this functional
derivative.
And in the same sense that
the Brownian particle,
the Brownian motion,
is trying to pull you
towards the minimum
of the potential,
this is an equation that,
if I kind of stop over here,
tries to put the particle
towards the minimum
of this beta H.
Now the reason that the Brownian
particle didn't go and stick
at one position, which was
the minimum, but fluctuated,
was of course, that we
added the random force.
So there is some kind of an
analog of a random force that
we can put either in front of
[? mu ?] or imagine that if we
added it to [? mu, ?]
and we put it over here.
Now for the case of
the Brownian particle,
the assumption was that if
I evaluate eta at some time,
and eta at another
time t2 and t1,
that this was related to 2D
delta function t1 minus t2.
Now of course here, at each
location, I have a noise term.
So this noise carries
an index, which
indicates the position, which
is, of course, a vector in D
dimension in principal.
And there is no reason to
imagine that the noise here
that comes from all kinds of
microscopic degrees of freedom
that we have
integrated out should
have correlation with the
noise at some other point.
So the simplest assumption is
to also put the delta function
in the positions, OK?
So if I take this beta
H that I have over there
and take the functional
derivative, what do I get?
I will get that the m of xt by
dt is the function of-- oops,
and I forgot to put a
the minus sign here.
The force is minus
the potential,
and this is basically
going down the gradient,
so I need to put that.
So I have to take a
derivative of this.
First of all I can take
a derivative with respect
to m itself.
I will get minus rm.
Well, actually, let's
put the minus out front.
And then I will get
the derivative of m
to the fourth, which is
[? 4umq, ?] all kinds of terms
like this.
Then the terms that come
from the derivatives
and taking the derivative
with respect to gradient
will give me K
times the gradient.
But then in the
functional derivative,
I have to take
another derivative,
converting this to minus
K log Gaussian of m.
And then I would have
L the fourth derivative
from the next term and so forth.
And on top of
everything else, I will
have the noise who's statistics
I have indicated above.
So this entity,
this equation, came
from the Landau-Ginzburg
model, and it
is called a time dependent
Landau-Ginzburg equation.
And so would be the analog of
the Brownian type of equation,
now for an entire field.
Now we're going to have
a lot of difficulty
in the short amount of time
that is left to us to deal
with this nonlinear
equation, so we
are going to do the same
thing that we did in order
to capture the properties
of the Landau-Ginzburg model
qualitatively.
Which is to ignore
nonlinearities,
so it's a kind of Gaussian
version of the model.
So what we did
was we linearized.
AUDIENCE: Question.
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why does the
sign in front of the K term
change relative to the others?
MEHRAN KARDAR: OK, so when you
have the function 0 of a field
gradient, et
cetera, you can show
that the functional
derivative, the first term
is the ordinary
type of derivative.
And then if you think about the
variations that are carrying m
and with the gradient and you
write it as m plus delta m
and then make sure that you
take the delta m outside,
you need to do an integration
by part that changes the sign.
And the next term
would be the gradient
of the phi by the [? grad ?]
m, and the next term
would be log [INAUDIBLE]
of [INAUDIBLE] gradient
of m squared and so forth.
It alternates and so by
explicitly calculating
the difference of
two functionals
with this integration evaluated
at m and m plus delta m
and pulling out everything
that is proportional to delta m
you can prove these expressions.
So we linearize this equation,
which I've already done that.
I cross out the mq term and
any other nonlinear terms,
so I only keep the linear term.
And then I do a
Fourier transform.
So basically I switch from
the position representation
to the Fourier transform that's
called m tilde of q, I think.
x is replaced with q.
And then the equation
for the field m linears.
The form separates out
into independent equations
for the components that
are characterized by q.
So the Fourier transform of the
left hand side is just this.
Fourier transform of
the right hand side
will give me minus mu
r plus K q squared.
The derivative of [INAUDIBLE]
will give me a minus q squared.
The derivative of the next term
L q to the forth, et cetera.
And I've only kept
the linear term,
so I have m tilde of q and t.
And then I have the
Fourier transforms
of the noise eta of x and t.
They [? call it ?] eta
tilde of q [? m. ?]
So you can see that
each mode satisfy
a separate linear equation.
So this equation is
actually very easy
to solve for any linear
equation m tilde of q and t.
If I didn't have the
noise, so I would
start with some value
at t [? close ?] to 0,
and that value would
decay exponentially
in the characteristic time
that I will call tao of q.
And 1 over tao of q is
simply this mu r plus K q2
and so forth.
Now once you have noise,
essentially each one
of these noises acts like
an initial condition.
And so the full
answer is an integral
over all of these noises from
0 tilde time t of interest.
Dt prime the noise that
occurs at a time t prime,
and the noise that occurs at
time t [? trime ?] relaxes
with this into the minus
t minus t prime tao of q.
So that's the solution to
that linear noisy equations,
basically [? sequencing ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
So one of the things
that we now see
is that essentially the
different Fourier components
of the field.
Each one of them
is independently
relaxing to something,
and each one of them
has a characteristic
relaxation time.
As I go towards smaller
and smaller values of q,
this rate becomes smaller,
and the relaxation time
becomes larger.
So essentially shortwave
wavelength modes
that correspond to large
q, they relax first.
Longer wavelength modes
will relax later on.
And you can see that the largest
relaxation time, tao max,
corresponds to q equals to 0
is simply 1 over [? nu ?] r.
So I can pluck this to a
max as a function of r,
and again in this theory,
the Gaussian theory,
we saw only makes sense as
long as all is positive.
So I have to look only
on the positive axis.
And I find that
the relaxation time
for the entire system for
the longest wavelength
actually diverges
as r goes to 0.
And recall that r,
in our perspective,
is really something that is
proportional to T minus Tc.
So basically we find that
as we are approaching
the critical point,
the time it takes
for the entirety of the
system or the longest
wavelength [? modes ?] to relax
diverges as 1 over T minus Tc.
There's an exponent that
shows this, so called,
critical slowing down.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In principal,
why couldn't you
have that r becomes negative
if you restrict your range of q
to be outside of some value
and not go arbitrarily
close to the origin.
MEHRAN KARDAR: You could, but
what's the physics of that?
See.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if
there is or is that not needed.
MEHRAN KARDAR: No.
OK, so the physics of that could
be that you have a system that
has some finite size, [? l. ?]
Then the largest q that you
could have [? or ?] the smallest
q that you could have would be
the [? 1/l. ?] So in principal,
for that you can go slightly
negative.
You still cannot go too negative
because ultimately this will
overcome that.
But again, we are
interested in singularities
that we kind of know arise
in the limit of [INAUDIBLE].
I also recall, there is a
time that we see as diverging
as r goes to 0.
Of course, we identified
before a correlation length
from balancing these two terms,
and the correlation length
is square root of K over r,
which is again proportional
to T minus Tc and diverges
with a square root singularity.
So we can see that this
tao max is actually related
to the psi squared over Nu K.
And it is also
related towards this.
We can see that our tao of
q, basically, if q is large
such that qc is larger than
1 and the characteristic time
is going to be 1 over [? nu ?] K
times the inverse of q squared.
And the inverse of q is
something like a wavelength.
Whereas, ultimately, this
saturates for qc what is less
than 1 [? long ?] wavelengths
to c squared over [? nu ?] K.
So basically you see
things at very short range,
at length scales that are
much less than the correlation
length of the system, that
the characteristic time will
depend on the length scale that
you are looking at squared.
Now you have seen times
scaling as length squared
from diffusion, so
essentially this
is some kind of a
manifestation of diffusion,
but as you perturb the system,
let's say at short distances,
there's some equilibrium system.
Let's say we do some
perturbation to it
at some point, and
that perturbation
will start to expand
diffusively until it reaches
the size of the correlation
length, at which point
it stops because essentially
correlation length is
an individual block that doesn't
know about individual blocks,
so the influence does not last.
So quite generally,
what you find--
so we solved the
linearized version
of the Landau-Ginzburg
model, but we
know that, say, the critical
behaviors for the divergence
of the correlation length
that is predicted here
is not correct in
three dimensions,
things get modified.
So these kind of exponents
that come from diffusion also
gets modified.
And quite generally, you
find that the relaxation time
of a mode of wavelength q
is going to behave something
like wavelength,
which is 1 over q,
rather than squared
as some exponent z.
And then there is some
function of the product
of the wavelength
you are looking at
and the correlation length
so that you will cross over
from one behavior
to another behavior
as you are looking
at length scales that
are smaller than the
correlation length
or larger than the
correlation length.
And to get what
this exponent z is,
you have to do study
of the nonlinear model
in the same sense
that, in order to get
the correction to the
exponent [? nu ?],
we had to do epsilon expansion.
You have to do
something similar,
and you'll fine that
at higher changes,
it goes like some correction
that does not actually
start at order of epsilon but
at order of epsilon squared.
But there's essentially
some modification
of the qualitative
behavior that we
can ascribe to the fusion
of independent modes
exists quite generally
and universal exponents
different from [? to ?]
will emerge from that.
Now it turns out that this
is not the end of the story
because we have seen
that the same probability
distribution can describe
a lot of different systems.
Let's say the focus on
the case of n equals to 1.
So then this Landau-Ginzburg
that I described
for you can describe,
let's say, the Ising model,
which describes
magnetizations that lie
along the particular direction.
So that it can also describe
liquid gas phenomena
where the order parameter is
the difference in density,
if you like, between
the liquid and the gas.
Yet another example
that it describes
is the mixing of an alloy.
So let's, for example, imagine
brass that has a composition
x that goes between 0 and 1.
On one end, let's say
you have entirely copper
and on the other and
you have entirely zinc.
And so this is how you
make brass as an alloy.
And what my other axis
is is the temperature.
What you find is that there
is some kind of phase diagram
such that you get a nice
mixture of copper and zinc
only if you are at
high temperatures,
whereas if you are
at low temperature,
you basically will
separate into chunks
that are rich copper and
chunks that are rich in zinc.
And you'll have a
critical demixing
point, which has exactly the
same properties as the Ising
model.
For example, this curve
will be characterized
with an exponent
beta, which would
be the beta of the Ising mode.
And in particular, if I
were to take someplace
in the vicinity of this and
try to write down a probability
distribution, that
probability distribution
would be exactly what
I have over there where
m is, let's say, the difference
between the two types of alloys
that I have compared to
each other over here.
So this is related to 2x minus
1 or something like that.
So as you go across your piece
of material close to here,
there will be
compositional variations
that are described by that.
So the question is, I know
exactly what the probability
distribution is for this system
to be an equilibrium given
this choice of m.
Again, with some set of
parameters, R, U, et cetera.
The question is-- is the
dynamics again described
by the same equation?
And the answer is no.
The same probability
of distribution
can describe-- or
can be obtained
with very different dynamics.
And in particular,
what is happening
in the system is that, if
I integrate this quantity m
across the system, I will
get the total number of 1
minus the other, which
is what is given to you,
and it does not change
as a function of time.
d by dt of this quantity is 0.
It cannot change.
OK.
Whereas the equation that
I have written over here,
in principle, locally, I
can, by adding the noise
or by bringing things
from the neighborhood,
I can change the value of m.
I cannot do that.
So this process of the
relaxation that would go
on in data graphs cannot be
described by the time dependent
on the Landau-Ginzburg
equation because you have this
conservation here.
OK.
So what should we do?
Well, when things are
conserved, like, say,
as the gas particles
move in this fluid,
and if I'm interested in
the number of particles
in some cube, then the
change in the number
of particles in some
cube in this room
is related to the gradient
of the current that
goes into that place.
So the appropriate way of
writing an equation that
describes, let's say, the
magnetization changing
as a function of time.
Given that you have
a conservation,
though, is to write it
as minus the gradient
of some kind of a current.
So this j is some
kind of a current,
and these would be vectors.
This is a current
of the particles
moving into the system.
Now, in systems that
are dissipative,
currents are related to the
gradient of some density
through the diffusion
constant, et cetera.
So it kind of makes sense to
imagine that this current is
the gradient of something that
is trying-- or more precisely,
minus the gradient
of something that
tries to bring the system
to be, more or less,
in its equilibrium state.
Equilibrium state, as we said,
is determined by this data H,
and we want to push
it in that direction.
So we put our data
H by dm over here,
and we put some kind
of a U over here.
Of course, I would
have to add some kind
of a conserved
random current also,
which is the analog of
this non-conserved noise
that I add over initially.
OK.
Now, the conservative version
of the equation, you can see,
you have two more
derivatives with respect
to what we had before.
And so once I-- OK.
So if we do something like
this, dm by dt is mu C.
And then I would
have [INAUDIBLE]
plus of R, rather
than by itself.
Actually, it would be the plus
then of something like R m
plus 4 U m cubed, and so forth.
And we are going to
ignore this kind of term.
And then there would
be high order terms
that would show up minus
k the fourth derivative,
and so forth.
And then there may be some
kind of a conserved noise
that I have to put outside.
OK.
So when I fully transform
this equation, what do I get?
I will get that dm by dt is--
let's say in the full space,
until there is a
function of qnt is minus
U C. Because of this plus, then
there's an additional factor
of q squared.
And then I have R
plus kq squared plus L
cubed to the fourth, et cetera.
And then I will have a
fully transformed version
of this conserved noise.
OK.
You can see that the difference
between this equation
and the previous equation is
that all of the relaxation
times will have an additional
factor of q squared.
And so eventually, this shortest
relaxation time actually
will glow like the size
of the system squared.
Whereas previously,
it was saturated
at the correlation length.
And because you will
have this conservation,
though, you have to
rearrange a lot of particles
keeping their numbers constant.
You have a much harder time
of relaxing the system.
All of the relaxation
times, as we see,
grow correspondingly
and become higher.
OK.
So indeed, for this class, one
can show that z starts with 4,
and then there
will be corrections
that would modify that.
So the-- yes?
AUDIENCE: How do we
define or how do we
do a realization of the
conserved noise, conserved
current-- conserved
noise in the room?
MEHRAN KARDAR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So it has some
kind of like correlation--
self-correlation
properties, I suppose,
because, if current
flowing out of some region,
doesn't it want to go in?
MEHRAN KARDAR: If
I go back here,
I have a good idea of what is
happening because all I need,
in order to ensure conservation,
is that the m by dt
is the gradient of something.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MEHRAN KARDAR: So I can put
whatever I want over here.
AUDIENCE: So if it's a scalar
or an [INAUDIBLE] field?
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes.
As long as it is sitting
under the gradient--
AUDIENCE: OK.
MEHRAN KARDAR: --it will be OK,
which means this quantity here
that I'm calling a to
z has a gradient in it.
And if you wait for
about five minutes,
we'll show that, because
of that in full space,
rather than having--
well, I'll describe
the difference between
non-conserved and conserved
noise in fully space.
It's much easier.
OK.
So actually, as far as what I
have discussed so far, which
is relaxation, I don't
really need the noise
because I can forget the noise.
And all I have
said-- and I forgot
the n tilde-- is that I
have a linear equation that
relaxes your variable to 0.
I can immediately read
off for the correlation,
then this-- a correlation times
what I need the noise for it
so that, ultimately, I don't go
to the medium is the potential,
but I go to this
pro-rated distribution.
So let's see what we have to
do in order to achieve that.
For simplicity, let's
take this equation.
Although I can take the
corresponding one for that.
And let's calculate-- because
of the presence of this noise,
if I run the same system
at different times,
I will have different
realizations of the noise
than if I had run many
versions of the system because
of the realizations of noise.
It's quantity and tilde
would be different.
It would satisfy some kind
of a pro-rated distribution.
So what I want to do is
to calculate averages,
such as the average of m tilde.
Let's say, q1 at time T
with m tilde q2 at time t.
And you can see already
from this equation
that, if I forget the part
that comes from the noise,
whatever initial
condition that I have
will eventually decay to 0.
So the thing that
agitates and gives
some kind of a randomness to
this really comes from this.
So let's imagine
that we have looked
at times that are
sufficiently long so
that the influence of
the initial condition
has died down.
I don't want to
write the other term.
I could do it, but it's kind
of boring to include it.
So let's forget that and
focus on the integral.
0 to t.
Now, if I multiply two
of these quantities,
I will have two
integrals over t prime.
All right.
Each one of them would decay
with the corresponding tau
of q.
In one case, tau of q1.
In the other case, tau of q2.
Coming from these things.
And the noise, q1 at time
to 1 prime, and noise q2
at time [? t2 prime. ?]
OK.
Now if I average over
the noise, then I
have to do an average over here.
OK.
Now, one thing that I forgot to
mention right at the beginning
is that, of course,
the average of this
we are going to set to 0.
It's the very least
that is important.
Right?
So if I do that,
clearly, the average
of one of these in
full space would
be 0 also because the full q is
related to the real space delta
just by an integral.
So if the average of
the integral is 0,
the average of this is 0.
So it turns out that, when
you look at the average of two
of them-- and it's a
very simple exercise
to just rewrite these things
in terms of 8 of x and t.
8 of x and t applied
average that you have.
And we find that the things that
are uncorrelated in real space
also are uncoordinated
in full space.
And so the variance
of this quantity
is 2d delta 1 prime
minus [? d2 prime. ?]
And then you have the analog
of the function in full space,
which always carries the
solution of a factor of 2 pi
to the d.
And it becomes a sum
of the q's, as we've
seen many times before.
OK.
So because of this
delta function,
this delta integral
becomes one integral.
So I have the integral 0 to t.
The 2t prime I can
write as just 1t prime,
and these two factors
merge into one.
It comes into minus t minus
t prime over tau of q,
except that I get
multiplied by a factor 2
since I have two of them.
And outside of the integral,
I will have this factor of 2d,
and then 2 pi to the d delta
function with 1 plus 2.
OK.
Now, we are really
interested-- and I already
kind of hinted at
that in the limit
where time becomes very large.
In the limit, where time
becomes a very large,
essentially, I need to calculate
the limit of this integral
as time becomes very large.
And as time grows
to very large, this
is just the integral
from 0 to infinity.
And the integral is going
to give me 2 over tau of q.
Essentially, you can see that
integrating at the upper end
will give me just 0.
Integrating at the
smaller end, it
will be exponentially
small as it
goes to infinity as a
factor of 2 over tau.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you
assuming or-- yeah.
Are you assuming that
tau of q is even in q
to be able to combine to--
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --2 tau?
So-- OK.
MEHRAN KARDAR: I'm thinking
of the tau of q's that we've
calculated over here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MEHRAN KARDAR: OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The e
times the [INAUDIBLE]
do the equation of something?
Right?
MEHRAN KARDAR: At this stage, I
am focusing on this expression
over here, where a is not.
But I will come to
that expression also.
So for the time being, this
d is just the same constant
as we have over here.
OK?
So you can see that
the final answer
is going to be d
over tau of q 2 pi
to the d delta
function q1 plus q2.
And if I use the value of tau
of q that I have, tau of q
is mu R plus kq squared,
which becomes d over mu R
plus kq squared and so forth.
2 pi to the d delta
function q1 plus q2.
So essentially, if I take this
linearized time dependent line
of Landau-Ginzburg equation,
run it for a very long time,
and look at the
correlations of the field,
I see that the
at the limit of long times,
satisfy this expression.
Now, what do I know if
I look at the top line
that I have for the
probability of distribution?
I can go and express that
probability of distribution
in full mode.
In the linear
version, I immediately
get that the probability
of m tilde of q
is proportional to a
product over different q's,
e to the minus R
plus kq squared,
et cetera, and tilde
of q squared over 2.
All right.
So when I look at the
equilibrium linear
as Landau-Ginzburg, I can
see that, if I calculate
the average of m of
q1, m of q2, then
this is an equilibrium average.
What I would get is 2 pi
to the d delta function
of q1 plus q2 because, clearly,
the different q's are recovered
from each other.
And for the particular value of
q, what I will get is 1 over R
plus kq squared and so forth.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So isn't the 2
over tau-- [INAUDIBLE]?
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes.
Over 2.
Yeah.
OK.
I changed because I
had 2d cancels the 2.
I would have to put
here tau of q over 2.
I had 2d times tau of q over 2.
So it's d tau.
And inverse of tau, I
have everything correct.
OK.
So if you make an even number
of errors, the answer comes up.
OK.
But you can now
compare this expression
that comes from equilibrium
and this expression that
comes from the long time
limit of this noisy equation.
OK So we want to
choose our noise
so that the stochastic
dynamics gives the same value
as equilibrium, just like we
did for the case of a Brownian
particular where you have some
kind of an Einstein equation
that was relating the strength
of the noise and the mobility.
And we see that here
all I need to do
is to ensure that d over
mu should be equal to 1.
OK.
Now, the thing is that,
if I am doing this,
I, in principle, can have a
different noise for each q,
and compensate by different
mobility for each q.
And I would get the same answer.
So in the non-conserved version
of this time dependent dynamics
that you wrote down,
the d was a constant
and the mu was a constant.
Whereas, if you want to get
the same equilibrium result out
of the conserved dynamics,
you can see that, essentially,
what we previously had as
mu became something that
is proportional to q squared.
So essentially, here, this
becomes mu C q squared.
So clearly, in order
to get the same answer,
I have to put my noise to be
proportional to q squared also.
And we can see that this kind of
conserved noise that I put over
here achieves that
because, as I said,
this conserved noise is the
gradient of something, which
means that, when I go to
fully space, if it be q,
it will be proportional to q.
And when I take its
variants, it's variants
will be proportional
to q squared.
Anything precisely canceled.
But you can see
that you also-- this
had a physical explanation in
terms of a conservation law.
In principle, you can cook
up all kinds of b of q and mu
of q.
As long as this equality is
satisfied, you will have,
for these linear
stochastic equations,
the guarantee that you would
always get the same equilibrium
result.
Because if you wait
for this dynamics
to settle down after long times,
you will get to the answer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I wonder how general
is this result for stochastic
[INAUDIBLE]?
MEHRAN KARDAR: OK.
AUDIENCE: But what I--
MEHRAN KARDAR: So
what I showed you
was with for linearized version,
and the only thing that I
calculated was the variance.
And I showed that the
variances were the same.
And if I have a Gaussian
problem of distribution,
the variance is
completely categorizable
with distribution.
So this is safe.
But we are truly interested
in the more general
non-Gaussian probability
of distribution.
So the question really is-- if
I keep the full non-linearity
in this story, would
I be able to show
that the probability
of distribution that
will be characterized
by all kinds of moments
eventually has the
same behavior as that.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
MEHRAN KARDAR: And the
answer is, in fact, yes.
There's a procedure that
relies on converting
this equation-- sorry.
One equation that
governs the evolution
of the full probability
as a function of time.
Right?
So basically, I can start
with a an initial probability
and see how this probability
evolves as a function of time.
And this is sometimes
called a master equation.
Sometimes, called a
[INAUDIBLE] equation.
And we did cover, in fact,
this in-- next spring
in the statistical
physics and biology,
we spent some time talking
about these things.
So you can come back to the
third version of this class.
And one can ensure that,
with appropriate choice
of the noise, the asymptotic
solution for this probability
distribution is
whatever Landau-Ginzburg
or other probability
distribution
that you need most.
AUDIENCE: So is this
true if we assume
Landau-Ginzburg potential
for how resistant?
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Maybe this is not a very
good-stated question,
but is there kind of like
an even more general level?
MEHRAN KARDAR: I'll
come to that, sure.
But currently, the way
that I set up the problem
was that we know some
complicated equilibrium
force that exist-- form of
the probability that exist.
And these kinds of
linear-- these kinds
of stochastic linear
or non-linear evolution
equations-- generally
called non- [INAUDIBLE]
equations-- one can show that,
with the appropriate choice
of the noise, we'll be able
to asymptotically reproduce
the probability of
distribution that we knew.
But now, the question
is, of course, you
don't know the probability
of distribution.
And I'll say a few
words about that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MEHRAN KARDAR: Anything else?
OK.
So the lesson of this
part is that the field
of dynamic or critical phenomena
is quite rich, much richer
than the corresponding
equilibrium critical phenomena
because the same
equilibrium state can
be obtained by various
different types of dynamics.
And I explained to you
just one conservation law,
but there could be
some combination
of conservation of energy,
conservation of something.
So there is a whole listing of
different universality classes
that people have targeted
for the dynamics.
But not all of this
was assuming that you
know what the ultimate answer
is because, in all cases,
the equations that
we're writing are
dependent on some kind of a
gradient descent conserved
or non-conserved around
something that corresponded
to the log of probability
of distribution
that we eventually want to put.
And maybe you don't
know that, and so
let me give you a particular
example in the context of,
let's say, surface
interface fluctuations.
Starting from things that
you know and then building
to something that
maybe you don't.
Let's first with the
case of a soap bubble.
So we take some kind of
a circle or whatever,
and we put a soap
bubble on top of it.
And in this case, the
energy of the formation--
the cost of the formation
comes from surface tension.
And let's say, the
cost of the deformation
is the changing area
times some sigma.
So I neglect the
contribution that
comes from the flat surface,
and see if I make a deformation.
If I make a deformation, I have
changed the area of the spin.
So there is a cost that is
proportion to the surface
tension times the
change in area.
Change in area locally
is the square root of 1
plus the gradient
of a height profile.
So what I can do is I can define
at each point on the surface
how much it has changed its
height from being perfectly
flat.
So h equals to 0 is flat.
Local area is the integral
dx dy of square root of 1
plus gradient of h
squared, minus 1.
That corresponds to the flat.
And so then you expand that.
The first term is going to
be the integral gradient of h
squared.
So this is the analog of
what we had over there, only
the first term.
So you would say that the
equation that you would write
down for this would be
all to some constant mu
proportional to the
variations of this,
which will give me something
like sigma Laplacian of h.
But because of the particles
from the air constantly
bombarding the
surface, there will
be some noise that
depends on where
you are on the surface in time.
And this is the
non-conserved version.
And you can from
this very quickly get
that the expectation value
of h tilde of q squared
is going to be proportional
to something like D
over mu sigma q squared,
because of this q squared.
And if you ask how
much fluctuations you
have in real space--
so that typical scale
of the fluctuations
in real space--
will come from integrating
1 over q squared.
And it's going to be
our usual things that
have this logarithmic
dependence, so there will
be something that ultimately
will go logarithmically
with the size of the system.
The constant of
proportionality will be
proportional to kt over sigma.
So you have to choose your D
and mu to correspond to this.
But basically, a soap
film, as an example
of all kinds of Goldstone
mode-like things
that we have seen.
It's a 2-dimensional entity.
We will have logarithmic
fluctuations-- not very big,
but ultimately, at
large enough distances,
it will have fluctuations.
So that was non-conserved.
I can imagine that,
rather than this,
I have the case of
a surface of a pool.
So here I have some
depth of water,
and then there's the surface
of the pool of water.
And the difference between this
case and the previous case--
both of them can be described
by a height function.
The difference is that
if I ignore evaporation
and condensation, the
total mass of water
is going to be conserved.
So I would need to have divided
t of the integral dx d qx
h of x and t to be 0.
So this would go into
the conserved variety.
And while, if I create a
ripple on the surface of this
compared to the surface of
that, the relaxation time
through this
dissipative dynamics
would be much longer in this
case as opposed to that case.
Ultimately, if I wait
sufficiently long time,
both of them would have
exactly the same fluctuations.
That is, you would go
logarithmically with the length
scale over which [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so now let's look at
another system that fluctuates.
And I don't know what
the final answer is.
That was the question,
maybe, that you asked.
The example that I will
give is the following--
so suppose that
you have a surface.
And then you have a
rain of sticky materials
that falls down on top of it.
So this material will come down.
You'll have something like this.
And then as time
goes on, there will
be more material that will come,
more material that will come,
more material that will come.
So there, because the particles
are raining down randomly
at different points, there
will be a stochastic process
that is going on.
So you can try to
characterize the system
in terms of a height that
changes as a function of t
and as a function of position.
And there could be all kinds
of microscopic things going on,
like maybe these
are particles that
are representing some kind
of a deposition process.
And then they come, they
stick in a particular way.
Maybe they can slide
on the surface.
We can imagine all kinds of
microscopic degrees of freedom
and things that we can put.
But you say, well, can
I change my perspective,
and try to describe the
system the same way that we
did for the case of
coarse grading and going
from without the
microscopic details
to describe the phenomenological
Landau-Ginzburg equation?
And so you say, OK, there
is a height that is growing.
And what I will write
down is an equation
that is very similar
to the equations
that I had written before.
Now I'm going to follow
the same kind of reasoning
that we did in the construction
of this Landau-Ginzburg model,
is we said that this weight
is going to depend on all
kinds of things that
relate to this height
that I don't quite know.
So let's imagine that there
is some kind of a function
of the height itself.
And potentially, just
like we did over there,
the gradient of the height,
five derivatives of the height,
et cetera.
And then I will start to
make an expansion of this
in the same spirit that I did
for the Landau-Ginzburg Model,
except that when I was doing
the Landau-Ginzburg Model,
I was doing the expansion
at the level of looking
at the probability distribution
and the log of the probability.
Here I'm making the expansion
at the level of an equation that
governs the dynamics.
Of course, in this
particular system,
that's not the end of story,
because the change in height
is also governed by this random
addition of the particles.
So there is some
function that changes
as a function of
position and time,
depending on whether,
at that time,
a particle was dropped down.
I can always take
the average of this
to be 0, and put that average
into the expansion of this
starting from a constant.
Basically, if I just
have a single point
and I randomly drop particles
at that single point,
there will be an
average growth velocity,
an average addition
to the height,
that averages over here.
But there will be fluctuations
that are going [INAUDIBLE].
OK but the constant
is the first term
in an expansion such as this.
And you can start thinking,
OK, what next order?
Can I put something
like alpha h?
Potentially-- depends
on your system--
but if the system is invariant
whether you started from here
or whether you started from
there-- something like gravity,
for example, is not
important-- you say, OK,
I cannot have any function of
h if my dynamics will proceed
exactly the same way if I
were to translate this surface
to some further up
or further down.
If I see that there's no change
in future dynamics on average,
then the dynamic
cannot depend on this.
OK, so we've got rid of that.
And any function
of h-- can I put
something that is
proportional to gradient of h?
Maybe for something I can,
but for h itself I cannot,
because h is a scalar gradient.
If h is a vector, I
can't set something
that is a scalar equal to a
vector, so I can't have this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't
you, in principle,
make your constant term in
front of the gradient also
a vector and [INAUDIBLE]?
MEHRAN KARDAR: You could.
So there's a whole set
of different systems
that you can be thinking about.
Right now, I want to focus
on the simplest system, which
is a scalar field, so
that my equation can
be as simple as
possible, but still we
will see it has
sufficient complication.
So you can see that
if I don't have them,
the next order term
that I can have
would be something
like a Laplacian.
So this kind of diffusion
equation, you can see,
has to emerge as a low-order
expansion of something
like this.
And this is the ubiquity of the
diffusion equation appearing
all over the place.
And then you could
have terms that
would be of the order of
the fourth derivative,
and so forth.
There's nothing wrong with that.
And then, if you
think about it, you'll
see that there is one
interesting possibility that
is not allowed for
that system, but is
allowed for this system, which
is something that is a scalar.
It's the gradient of h squared.
Now I could not have added this
term for the case of the soap
bubble for the
following reason--
that if I reverse the
soap bubble so that h
becomes minus h, the dynamics
would proceed exactly
as before.
So the soap bubble has a
symmetry of h going to minus h,
and so that symmetry should
be preserved in the equation.
This term breaks that symmetry
because the left-hand side
is odd in h, whereas the
right-hand side of this term
would be even in h.
But for the case of the growing
surface-- and you've seen
things that are growing.
And typically, if I
give you something
that has grown like the
tree trunk, for example,
and if I take the
picture of a part of it,
and you don't see where the
center is, where the end is,
you can immediately
tell from the way
that the shape of this
object is, that it is growing
in some particular direction.
So for growth systems, that
symmetry does not exist.
You are allowed to have
this term, and so forth.
Now the interesting
thing about this term
is that there is no beta
h that you can write down
that is local-- some
function of h such
that if you take a functional
derivative with respect to h,
it will reproduce that
term-- just does not exist.
So you can see that
somehow immediately,
as soon as we liberate ourselves
from writing equations that
came from functional
derivative of something,
but potentially have
physical significance,
we can write down new terms.
So this is actually--
also, you can do
this, even for two particles.
A potential v of x1 and x2 will
have some kind of derivatives.
But if you write
dynamical equations,
there are dynamical
equations that
allow you to rotate
1 x from x1 to x2.
That kind of term
will never come
from taking the derivative.
So fine.
So this is a candidate
equation that
is obtained in this context--
something that is grown.
We say we are not
interested in it's
coming from some
underlying weight,
but presumably,
this system still,
if I look at it at
long times, will
have some kind of fluctuations.
All the fluctuations of
this growing surface,
like the fluctuations
of the soap bubble,
and they have this
logarithmic dependence.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: So why doesn't that
term-- what if I put in h times
that term that we want
to appear and then I
vary with respect to h?
A term like what we want to pop
out together with other terms?
MEHRAN KARDAR: Yeah,
but those other terms,
what do you want
to do with them?
AUDIENCE: Well, maybe they're
not acceptable [INAUDIBLE]?
MEHRAN KARDAR: So you're
saying why not have a term that
is h gradient of h squared?
Functional derivative of that
is gradient of h squared.
And then you have a term
that is h Laplacian-- it's
a gradient of,
sorry, gradient of h.
And then you expand this.
Among the terms that
you would generate
would be a term that
is h, a Laplacian of h.
This term violates
this condition
that we had over here.
And you cannot separate
this term from that term.
So what you
describe, you already
see at the level over here.
It violates translation of
symmetry in [? nature ?].
And you can play around
with other functions.
You come to the same conclusion.
OK, so the question is, well,
you added some term here.
If I look at this surface
that has grown at large time,
does it have the same
fluctuations as we had before?
So a simple way
to ascertain that
is to do the same kind
of dimensional analysis
which, for the Landau-Ginzburg,
was a prelude to doing
renormalization.
So we did things like
epsilon expansion, et cetera.
But to calculate that there
was a critical dimension of 4,
all we needed to do
was to rescale x and m,
and we would
immediately see that mu
goes to mu, b to the 4
minus D or something--
D minus 4, for example.
So we can do the
same thing here.
We can always move
to a frame that
is moving with the
average velocity,
so that we are focusing
on the fluctuations.
So we can basically
ignore this term.
I'm going to rescale
x by a factor of b.
I'm going to rescale time by
a factor of b to something
to the z.
And this z is kind
of indicative of what
we've seen before-- that somehow
in these dynamical phenomena,
the scaling of time and space
are related to some exponent.
But there's also
an exponent that
characterizes how
the fluctuations in h
grow if I look at systems
that are larger and larger.
In particular, if I had
solved that equation,
rather than for a soap
bubble in two dimensions,
for a line-- for a string that
I was pulling so that I had
line tension-- the
one-dimensional version of it,
the one-dimensional version of
an integral of 1 over q squared
would be something
that would grow
with the size of the system.
So there I would have a
chi of 1/2, for example,
in one dimension.
So this is the general thing.
And then I would say that
the first equation, dhy dt,
gets a factor of
b to the chi minus
z, because h scaled
by a factor of chi,
t scaled by a factor of z,
the term sigma Laplacian of h
gets a factor of b
to the chi minus 2
from the two derivatives here--
sorry, the z and the 2 look
kind of the same.
This is a z.
This is a 2.
And then the term
that is proportional
to this non-linearity that
I wrote down-- actually, it
is very easy, maybe worthwhile,
to show that sigma to the 4th
goes with a factor of
b to the chi minus 4.
It is always down by a factor of
two scalings in b with respect
to a Laplacian-- the
same reason that when
we were doing the
Landau-Ginzburg.
We could terminate the series
at order of gradient squared,
because higher-order
derivatives were irrelevant.
They were scaling to 0.
But this term grows
like b to the 2 chi,
because it's h squared, minus 2,
because there's two gradients.
Now thinking about
the scaling of eta
takes a little bit of thought,
because what we have-- we
said that the average
of eta goes to 0.
The average of eta at
two different locations
and two different times--
it is these particles that
are raining down--
they're uncorrelated
at different times.
They're uncorrelated
at different positions.
There's some kind
of variance here,
but that's not important to us.
If I rescale t by a factor
of b, delta of bt-- sorry,
if I scale t by a factor of b
to the z, delta of b to the zx
will get a factor
of b to the minus z.
This will get a factor
of b to the minus d.
But the noise, eta,
is half of that.
So what I will have is b to
the minus z plus d over 2 times
eta on the rescalings
that I have indicated.
I get rid of this term.
So this-- divide by
b to the chi minus z.
So then this becomes bh y dt
is sigma b to the z minus 2.
Maybe I'll write it in
red-- b to the z minus 2.
This becomes sigma to the
4, b to the z minus 4.
And then lambda over 2.
This is Laplacian of h.
This, for derivative of
h, this is Laplacian of h.
This term becomes b to the chi
plus z minus 2, gradient of h
squared.
And the final term becomes b to
the chi minus d minus z over 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MEHRAN KARDAR: b to the
minus chi-- you're right.
And then, actually, this I-- no?
Minus chi minus d over 2
minus d over 2 [INAUDIBLE],
That's fine.
So I can make this
equation to be invariant.
So I want to find
out what happens
to this system if I find
some kind of an equation,
or some kind of behavior
that is scale invariant.
You can see that immediately,
my choice for the first term
has to be z equals to 2.
So basically, it
says that as long
as you're governed by
something that is diffusive,
so that when you go to Fourier
space, you have q squared,
your relaxation times
are going to have
this diffusive character,
where time is distance squared.
Actually, you can see that
immediately from the equation
that this diffusion time
goes like distance squared.
So this is just a
statement of that.
Now, it is the noise that
causes the fluctuations.
And if I haven't made
some simple error,
you will find that the
coefficient of the noise term
becomes scale invariant,
provided that I choose it
to be z minus d over 2 for chi.
And since my z was
2, I'm forced to have
chi to be 2 minus d over 2.
And let's see if it
makes sense to us.
So if I have a surface such
as the case of the soap bubble
in two dimensions, chi is 0.
And 0 is actually
this limiting case
that would also be a logarithm.
If I go to the case of d equals
to 1-- like pulling a line
and having the line fluctuate--
then I have 2 minus 1
over 2, which is
1/2, which means
that, because of
thermal fluctuations,
this line will look
like it a random walk.
You go a distance x.
The fluctuations
in height will go
like the square root of that.
OK?
So all of that is fine.
You would have done
exactly the same answer
if you had just gotten a
kind of scaling such as this
for the case of
the Gaussian Model
without the nonlinearities.
But for the Gaussian
Model with nonlinearities,
we could also then estimate
whether the nonlinearity u
is relevant.
So here we see that the
coefficient of our nonlinearity
is lambda, is
governed by something
that is chi plus z minus 2.
And our chi is 2 minus z over 2.
z minus 2 is 0.
So whether or not this
nonlinearity is relevant,
we can see depends
on whether you're
above or below two dimensions.
So when you are
below two dimensions,
this nonlinearity is relevant.
And you will certainly
have different types
of scaling phenomena
then what you
predict by the case of the
diffusion equation plus noise.
Of course, the
interesting case is
when you are at the
marginal dimension of 2.
Now, in terms of when you do
proper renormalization group
with this nonlinearity,
you will find that,
unlike the nonlinearity of
the Landau-Ginzburg, which
is marginally irrelevant
in four dimensions.
du by dl was minus u
squared, this lambda
is marginally relevant.
d lambda by dl is proportional
to plus lambda squared.
It is relevant marginality--
marginally relevant.
And actually, the
epsilon expansion
gives you no information about
what's happening in the system.
So people have then done
numerical simulations.
And they find that there
is a roughness that
is characterized by an exponent,
say something like 0.4.
So that when you look at
some surface that is grown,
is much, much rougher than
the surface of a soap bubble
or what's happening on
the surface of the pond.
And the key to all of this is
that we wrote down equations
on the basis of
this generalization
on symmetry that we had
learned, now applied
to this dynamical
system, did an expansion,
found one first term.
And we found it to be relevant.
And is actually not
that often that you
find something that is
relevant, because then it
is a reason to celebrate.
Because most of the time,
things are irrelevant,
and you end up with boring
diffusion equations.
So find something
that is relevant.
And that's my last
message to you.